>> So, our project is
actually to develop
a domain-specific language
for the class of applications
comprising ML and data processing
in constrained IoT devices.
So, just to give
a background, actually,
I had started
an industrial IoT startup,
and this is actually
my monitoring device.
So, it has Wi-Fi and does
on-board data sensing,
the communication
data processing,
everything is done on the device.
So, it actually had a
programmable rule engine
data aggregation.
So, this is actually
my starting point
for me to work into
the language aspect
of IoT data processing
ML applications.
So, the problem and
the motivation.
So, it's computing applications
are some more and
more becoming
increasingly popular
in constrained IoT devices.
A prime example is
Interactive Cane application
developed by Microsoft
research right here.
Actually, you can see
the device developed by Mecer.
So, basically it allows
visually challenged people to
interact with their phone
like gesture with
their walking stick,
and ML is actually
implemented on the device,
which only has
a few kilobytes of RAM.
So, the constrained
embedded applications
have limited resources.
There is no resource
virtualization.
Energy, timing are
important considerations,
and our motivation is the lack of
current programming tools
to support development of
modular data pipelines with
compile-time feedback to
the programmer on
resource usages.
As Alan Perlis famously said,
"Programmers know the value of
everything and
the cost of nothing."
So, we want to make the program
aware of the cost of
memory and compute
an energy overheads
of enrolling their application.
So, there are three
overarching objectives.
One is to provide
compile-time feedback
on power timing and
resource usage.
So, obviously, through
static analysis.
Second, to enable
optimizations not support or
unlikely to be done by
standard compilers.
Third, which is important
for a programmer,
clarity, concision and
programmer convenience.
Actually, as of
now we have ported
the entire Interactive
Cane application
written by Microsoft Research.
Original applications
are written in C++.
So, we have
a fully working ported
application in our DSL,
which we will demo
at the end, and we
have one fourth code
size reduction.
So, we just kind of
important for programmer,
program maintenance and
debugging and so on.
Also work in progress,
short paper on the language
has been accepted in
ACM SIGBED, EMSOFT conference.
So, what is the challenge in
static analysis of power,
timing, resource usage
in embedded systems?
So, we need to able
to reason about I/O.
Of course, we can
analyze a program and
a compare the worst case
execution time of computations,
but we also need to be
able to reason about I/O.
It's impractical to integrate
a full hardware and
model into the analysis.
Also, there is a need to use
low-level C/C++ libraries
for hardware access.
So, interoperability
with existing libraries
are very important for
the language to be adopted.
So, we have come up
with this concept
of effect specifications.
So, the effects of library calls
can be made explicit through
effect specifications and we
will show some code snippets.
So, we can actually
annotate different kinds of
effects like
resource acquisition,
which is useful for analyzing
resource conflicts.
Also, we'll give an
example of how it can also
be used to analyze
security and privacy also.
CPU time consumption,
power state change,
read/write on memory objects,
so this is useful for
memory optimization.
So, we know that whether
an object being passed
through library code
is getting right door updated by
the library code. Timed events.
So, this is an example of
our effect specification for
a few Arduino library
function calls
because eigen applications
actually uses Arduino library.
So, this actually
the fastest statement
assigns the effect.
So, this means that if
we call pinPeripheral n,
which is an Arduino
library function,
it has the effect of acquiring
the pin without reason.
So pin, this is actually
the resource capability class
which can be refined.
So, we can for example, define
with specific operations.
So, this means that
this particular
the model which invokes
this pinPeripheral
actually acquires pin capability
with the resource address then.
Similarly, serial print line.
So, there are different kinds
of capabilities here.
The other is CPU time.
So, if we have poldio,
program dio basically
that consume CPU cycles.
So that effect can actually
be specified like this,
and this has a memory effect so
getFIFOBytes actually updates
the buf memory effect,
CPU cycle effect
power state change.
So, these kind of side effects
of library function
calls can actually
be made explicit through
our fixed specification.
So, that is one of our
contributions, key contributions.
Second, is do optimizations
that a traditional
compiler may not do.
So, actually one of the
things we've done is,
we actually have
a compiler managed heap.
So, if you want to reuse memory
in a traditional program,
you have to actually
do garbage collection
or explicit memory management.
But here the compiler actually
compares the lifetimes
of objects like
matrices and vectors and
reuses them. Of course,
this is similar.
As Shriram said, this is
similar to register allocation,
but difference is
that registered as
an atomic object whereas
an array is actually
not an atomic object.
So, a part of the
array could be reused
by some other object,
and the rest of the array block
could reused by
some other object and so on.
An interesting issue we
encountered here was that in
traditional memory allocation,
we have this fragmentation,
internal fragmentation,
external fragmentation.
Here, we also have encountered
lifetime fragmentation.
So, for example,
if I try to reuse
memory across two objects
having different lifetimes,
and if they are far
apart, actually,
we're actually losing some amount
of time when the buffer
is actually free,
not used by anybody.
So, we actually want to reduce
lifetime fragmentation as well
as internal fragmentation.
Second is, we can have
operation of our allocation.
For example, this is
a [inaudible] operation,
concatenation of two vectors.
So, if A concat B occurs,
then A and B can
actually be allocated
in adjacent memory,
and the operation can
actually be eliminated.
Then fusion of matrix-vector
loops, then in-place update.
So, in-place for example,
let us say we are casting
an integer array to float array.
So, the alignment sizes are same.
We can actually do
an in-place update,
so again, reducing
the memory usage.
Then finally, generate
efficient state machine
that automatically enters CPU
sleep mode when it is idle.
So basically, a traditional
static electricity
actually allocates along
the linear address line.
We actually allocate,
our allocator works in
the space where the y-axis is
actually the address line,
and x-axis is actually
the pipeline lifetime.
So, we actually want to
fill this entire area.
So, basically we want to optimize
by filling this entire area,
and here you can
see that these two.
So, this is our address,
you can see these two
buffers actually share
the same address region
because they have
different lifetimes.
There's actually
the memory layout output
from our ID so it's
automatically generated.
>> Question. Is lifetime
based on the method in which-
>> Yes. So, basically we do
a whole program analysis.
>> Is it later a form of
escape analysis
that you are doing?
>> No. So, basically
the pipeline applications,
we basically have
a cyclic execution,
same pipeline repeatedly, right?
So, if you take one
execution of the pipeline,
lifetime is the duration
in the program execution
meant that variable active,
either defined or used.
Similarly, we have a very
basic worst case
execution time analysis.
Software as a computer analysis,
pretty simple because
CPU is pretty simple.
There isn't caching
and those kind
of advanced features
are not there.
But we have lot of I/O.
So, basically we
incorporate I/O into
our timing analysis by
using our annotations.
So, for example, the acquisition
does a blocking I/O,
and because of
our annotation we can
actually capture that
into our analysis.
So, we know that mpu_acq
actually takes this
many CPU cycles.
So, this is again the
output from our IDE.
>> Can I ask you a question?
>> Yes.
>> Do you do this kind of
analysis moderately or
you just in line everything and
just do this as
one method finally?
>> Yeah. We do whole program
analysis, non-modular.
>> You in line
everything and you just
then analyze as one method?
>> Yeah. Actually, it's
done in a modular fashion.
So, we don't really
in-line anything.
>> So, for every method
you compute an effect?
>> Yes.
>> Somebody has something like
that maybe just chain them up?
>> Yeah, exactly. So, it's
done in a modular fashion.
But actually we follow
the chain of executions.
So, we complete in
a modular fashion
and then compute aggregate.
The last, but not the least,
is clarity in
programmer convenience.
So, we have built-in
matrix/vector operations
with dimensions.
So, we have dimensions
integrated into the type system.
So, if I'm trying to multiply
two matrices which do not
have compatible dimensions,
we can give a compile-time error.
We actually have
a built-in circular vector.
Circular vector are
usually used in
data acquisition applications
because we want to keep,
in a latest, an elements.
So, and can we use like
a linear vector by
the programmer and we have
modular pipeline stage.
So, I'll show you
some code snippets
with declarative
pipeline specification.
Separation of errors handling
policy from the main code,
and we can actually
have a library
of pre-defined pipeline stages,
we'll show you a few examples.
Interoperability with
C/C++ libraries,
and we actually have
built-type browser-based IDE.
So, individual modules we
are actually calling
flow modules.
So, there is a flow routine,
there's acquisition routines
doesn't take any input.
So, once a stage is completed,
data generation actually, can
pass the data to the next stage
by invoking the next.
So, this is like asynchronously
training this thing,
and if it doesn't want
it doesn't need to call.
So, the module can actually
control whether the generacy
flow to the next stage
or control like should
start execution the beginning
of the pipeline.
Then, there is a next stage.
So, past data's actually
flows to the next stage,
and processes, and so on.
Then, icane applications
actually can be
declared as a pipeline
specification
here in our language.
You can see the different stages,
and these are like
pre-built reusable modules.
So only if data has
changed from the past,
the next stage will be executed.
We can also limit the rate.
So we can actually do
some very simple privacy
kind of analysis.
For example, this our
only module which
acquires sensor port.
We know that from
the effects specification.
And this our only module
which acquires data port,
that means this is
the only module that transmits.
Here, we have
rate limit in-between.
So this access like
information barrier
from acquisition to output.
So even if if it reads
the individual blocks us,
like black box without even
really going into anything,
we know that the sensor data
can flow to the output
with a rate limit
of only one data item
per two seconds.
So we can do some
very simple privacy,
we can make some very simple
privacy statements from
the specification.
Here's a code snippet
of our ring buffer.
So there's a ring buffer and
then we can push new values.
So we can multiply matrix
with the ring buffer,
we can just use it as
a normal linear vector.
And if it access the other line,
we'll always get
the oldest value.
So it's very convenient
for the programmer.
This is our workshop outcome.
Actually, when we came here,
we just had a concept,
we had not done any development.
So we actually build the entire
via develop the grammar.
So what we first did
was we actually,
we had an idea of our language.
So we ported the icon application
first into our syntax.
So that informed
our program language development
and then we defend the grammar.
So all the green
blocks you see here,
actually, have been built
during the workshop.
Rahul [inaudible] actually
has developed the DSL,
which automatically convert
floating point to fixed point,
we are planning to
integrate with that.
Compiler actually,
currently, outputs
optimized C state machine.
Since it's actually
modular compiler,
we can actually have
different targets.
Tomorrow we can target
another target.
We also have a fully ported
MSR icane application
working, we'll demo it.
So we've got the
entire thing working.
Thanks to [inaudible]
and Don for helping
in debugging all
the algorithm implementation.
Future work, we need to be
planning to investigate the
effect specification further.
Hopefully, we'll
get the good inputs
from the Msoft also regarding
this particular line of
investigation, IDE enhancements.
We can actually
have other targets
like.NET Microframework,
LLVM IR, and so on.
Actually, right now,
we're not implemented
the type checker so that is
another future work
to do. Thank you.
So now, we will also
briefly demo the IDE.
So currently, the board
is actually running icane
ported in our DSL.
So this is IDE.
>> This our IDE?
>> Just show the serial.
See, a very simple
serial monitor we have
built into the IDE.
It actually shows the sensor
of transporting,
we have Bluetooth,
we are just printing.
Should we connect?
So anyway the credit for
the algorithm is not ours.
But anyway, the thing is
we have ported it into
our DSL and it's working.
We actually have one-fourth
code size reduction
from C++ to our DSL.
>> And we have
memory analysis part here.
>> [inaudible] Matrix in terms of
ultimate power
reduction or other.
>> No, right now, we are actually
able to do the analysis,
but optimizations we don't have.
Actually, another things is
just compiler can
actually give errors,
like syntax errors
and type errors.
Our compiler can actually
give, for example, let us say,
that because of effect
annotations, let us say,
that programmer is making
a blocking function call with
an undefined amount of time.
For example, trying to connect to
our network, a blocking function.
So the compiler can
actually give error,
a warning to the
programmer saying,
"This function might
take forever."
So those kind of
compile-time feedback we
can give and probably also
suggest some automatic fixes.
>> So.
>> Yeah.
>> So just trying to
understand demo, right?
So icane is written in C++?
>> Yeah.
>> And you said that you sorted
the natural language
alongside it.
So did you reuse some of
that C++ when you
implemented your-
>> No. Actually, if you
can rotate the proton.
So basically, the basic flow
is completely written
in our language.
>> Okay.
>> Only the I/O libraries we
are using are in the libraries.
>> Okay.
>> Like for reading from
the serial port and.
>> So in your DSL,
when you said proton.
>> Yeah.
>> It wasn't calling the C++?
>> No. It's calling
our implementation programs.
>> [inaudible].
>> I see.
>> So actually, all the modules
listed there are actually
written in our language.
Only library functions we
are using are actually
I/O libraries.
>> Okay.
>> Like reading from I2C bus,
and serial port, and so on.
>> So I had another question.
>> Yes.
>> So you mentioned that
with your technique,
you can sort of do a better
memory allocation?
>> Yes.
>> Right?
>> Yeah.
>> Did you see that
affect [inaudible]?
>> Yeah. Actually,
I'll just show you.
For this particular application,
we didn't see
a big gain with that.
But one thing is that you can see
that this is a lifetime,
and this is a memory address.
So you can see many of
the large arrays are actually
having the entire lifetime.
So basically, that means
they are persistence of mem.
So but here, you can see
some memory usage like
norm access and featureVector
and these are like re-used.
So but one thing is
that, of course,
whatever optimizations
are useful,
we only have a few kilobytes.
Second thing is that it
frees the programmer
from worrying about for
example, let's say,
he has allocated a local array
and it is passed
to the next stage,
whether it is stock a location
or heap statically.
It frees the programmer from
worrying about where to allocate.
So basically whether it is
a local array or global array,
all the non like arrays
and matrices and vectors
in our language,
we allocate in
the compiler managed heap.
That frees the programmer
from worrying about,
the one worry is kind
of taken care of.
>> So the proton code in
your DSL was a C++ working
with [inaudible] code?
>> Proton.
>> Roughly speaking. I
thought that we can do that-
>> Yeah, we can show it.
Because we are having
declaratives syntax
for arrays, we don't need loops.
We don't- So for example-
>> All thes closer to MATLAB.
>> Exactly.
>> [inaudible]
>> Proton is just
[inaudible] of coding
our language, but as in C++-
>> If we also
consider the library.
For example, we need to use
libraries for vector like,
circular buffers and so on.
So if we consider all that
code in C++ code, would be.
>> But probably the C++ one
can be faster than
MATLAB for sure.
>> Yeah.
>> But, I don't know if
it is faster than yours.
>> Yeah, exactly right.
>> Yeah, but you know.
>> So, because ultimately,
we generate an optimized
C state machine.
So, definitely we actually run
it like bare-metal speeds.
So, we don't add any over.
Idea is that, actually
have abstractions,
which have zero cost.
>> I have a few questions.
>> Yeah.
>> Wasn't this lifetime analysis?
If you look at escape analysis
that's applied to
object-oriented languages.
Say for, languages like Java,
where you try to instead
of deep allocation,
you'll see the lifetime is
bounded by the method
in which it got
created it could
be stack allocated
and likewise it could
otherwise try to extend.
>> Yeah.
>> So, how much is your technique
going beyond
these established ways
of doing lifetime analysis?
I mean, those are typically,
looking at only the
method boundary.
>> Yeah.
>> It looks like
you're also going
beyond that in
terms of iteration,
counts, and all kinds of-
can you clarify a bit?
>> Yes. Yeah, I'll do that.
>> How much you are
going beyond that.
>> Yeah. So, I'll just
show you the pipeline.
So, actually first of
all, in our analysis,
if we take our analysis routine,
so this is a pipeline stage.
What we do is, we're starting
with the first stage,
we basically do
a whole program there.
We look at what is the next
stage after the first stage?
So we do a whole
program analysis.
Whenever we pass some objects,
we actually do an alias,
so that means a lot.
>> Even standard methods
will do, right?
>> Right. Right. Right.
>> If you look at
the escape analysis
for Java, they will all
do inter procedural?
>> Right. Right. Right. But
I don't think that there is
any allocation today which can
reuse part of the object memory.
>> I know of techniques developed
30 years ago which were
doing these kinds of things.
It looks like you're also doing
some further iteration
level analysis also,
but it wasn't very clear.
>> Okay. So, I will explain
to you our algorithm.
So, first of all, basically
if you look at the escape
analysis you mentioned,
you are actually looking
at converting to
stack allocation the objects
used within that function, right?
So, in our case, we are actually
doing a whole program analysis.
We are taking the entire program,
and seeing how we can
actually reuse the objects.
So, basically what we do is-
>> Those techniques also
do good program analysis.
Don't think they
only look at within
a method because when you're
making other method calls,
you have to determine what's
the impact of that method
on any kind of aliasing,
any kind of pointers, and so
on that have been set up.
Don't think
those techniques don't
do good program
analysis, they do.
>> Okay.
>> That can be your novelty.
>> Okay. So, basically
this is our entire
pipeline lifetime.
So, first of all
we only look at big objects
like matrix and vector objects,
not primitive types.
So, basically what we do is,
let us say this is
the address line.
Initially, what we do is we
actually create regions,
so each region is
a contiguous block of memory.
We actually allocate a separate
region for each object,
then we try it and try to
optimize and merge regions.
So actually our algorithm how it
works till we reach
a fixed point,
where no more
optimization is possible.
So, let us say we
have another object,
we have another object.
This is the entire pipeline,
one cycle of the pipeline.
What we do is, so for example,
let's say that, eraser?
You cannot erase it. But in
our case, we can reallocate.
Initially, we start with
separate addresses,
and then we see here that
this particular object does
not overlap with this-
the lifetime does
not overlap with
this object, then we reuse.
So, we merge them
into a single region.
So, now that region
has one block with
this lifetime and another block
with this lifetime.
Now, we have another block here,
which are non-overlapping
lifetime with this,
so we again merge it.
So, now we have one block
with this much lifetime.
We still have a remaining block
with- so we actually
continue iteration like this
till we- and of course,
there could be another region
which is actually
partially-merged,
and then we can actually merge
partially-merged regions until we
reach a fixed point.
That is basically our-
>> The question was, when
you had these library calls,
you had these annotations, right?
Which was specifying
the resource and  and so on.
>> Yes, yes.
>> Is your compiler
providing any assistance,
or the language providing
any other assistance in
terms of helping come
up with those estimates
in the first place?
>> So, right now, no.
Basically, the idea was that,
so if you look at- so,
I developed the
application program,
I should not have
burdened with this.
That was the whole idea. If you
look at our effect annotation,
so this needs to be done.
There is no annotation in the-
>> Isn't the programmer
coming up with it?
>> No, this is not
the Library Developer.
>> Yeah, okay, the library?
But still the programmer-
>> Yeah. No, so once it
is done for a library,
the library functions can be
reused in application program,
just like- for example,
I can make a call to the pin
peripheral and something.
So, the Application Programmer
doesn't need to worry
about anything,
then it'll be
automatically pulled from
the FX specification
from the library.
It'll pattern match
the library call
and pull the effect
specification,
then include in the analysis.
So, it needs to be done
once for a library,
and then reused in
the application.
That was a- yes.
>> Traditionally Compilers
have shied away from doing
inter-procedural whole
program analysis
because that is closer
to the compilation type.
So what is the
compilation time frame
of a linear quadratic
method programs?
>> I haven't done
an analysis on that.
Of course, some of our algorithms
are definitely
non-linear right now.
But one reason we are
able to- actually,
if you look at NesC, for example.
NesC actually did
whole program analysis
for many other- because recently,
the program size is small.
Because we are actually, unlike
a traditional folk, for example,
if we look at
a traditional application,
it may run to 100,000 or
millions of lines of code.
But, whereas here,
the application size is less,
so that is one reason why we are
actually able to afford
our whole program analysis.
Another reason is that,
unlike a traditional program,
an embedded program is
closed over all the
important parameters.
For example, allocation size and
all those things are
actually specified
somewhere as a constant
in the program.
Whereas, if we look at
a traditional
application for example,
the application we
allocate a link list based
on some user input or
the size may be based
on some user input,
or it may read from some file.
So, it's not really
possible to do
this kind of analysis in
a traditional context at all.
But here because
the program is closed,
working in a closed environment,
we are actually able to
do this kind of analysis.
It is closed because of
two reasons, one is of course,
is because of constraints,
you don't have enough memory.
Second is safety.
Actually, if you have
a look at- so there is
a C dialect called MISRA C by
Motor Industries Centers
Association for safety purposes.
That actually disallows the old
dynamic aspects of C language,
pointer manipulation,
memory allocation.
So, that the other concern is,
not more than
memory constraints safety.
But anyway, coming
back to the point is,
because the program
size is small,
we are able to end because
the program is closed.
>> So, I have a more high level
of question about the impact.
So, I'm trying to
think about like me
as a programmer of CNIP,
and I'm trying to
understand what is
the complex part of me
writing this program.
I'm probably not going to
write the proton library.
So, in fact, somebody
at Amazon is probably
going to write
an optimized proton library
and give it to me.
So, I don't need
a DSL fo that part.
I'm trying to understand
where is the DSL
helping me as
an Application Developer.
Is it in encoding
new kinds of gestures,
new kinds of algorithms?
So, where is the benefit to
me as a programmer, say,
if you reduce the development
time of this mark
and allocation? I'm not sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's definitely
a very good question.
Of course, we haven't
investigated the full impact yet,
but one area is
that, for example,
let us say that- so,
once we have a set of
library of reusable blocks,
we can actually build pipelines
using simpler declarative
specification.
And it's very easy to change.
For example, instead of proton,
we want to actually use
some other library
instead of data like NPO,
since of this particular sensor,
we want to use some other- so,
it's very easy to maintain
the application
chain cycle, I feel.
So, if we look at
the C++ Icane application.
Actually it's a C++ state machine
which actually calls all these,
so everything is coupled
with each other,
so the're is close coupling.
Whereas, we have
removed the coupling,
and if you look at
a particular module,
there are absolutely
no reference to,
there is no coupling to
any other module here.
Not only that, so the model
can do two things.
One is that, it can decide
what data it can process,
what data is sent to next stage,
whether it should send
data to the next stage.
So, these three things
can actually be decided,
programmed in the module
without actually
coupling with
any other existing module.
So, I think it reduces
coupling impose modularity,
and we can actually
build pipelines simply by
mixing and matching blocks.
I feel there could be
some- and another thing is that,
because we have this
declarative specification,
we have pre-built modules,
which we can give predefined
meaning like rate limit.
We can also do this kind of
privacy analysis and so on.
>> Yeah, maybe. I realize this
is preliminary it might be
useful to understand the benefits
of your module particle things,
decouple, what happened in
the proton part and
what is happening in
the application part?
And then particles
outside similarity,
the core benefits
and energy benefits,
whatever they're doing.
Have they managed to
decoupled those too?
>> Okay.
>> Because protons probably
going to be written once.
>> Right. Right.
>> The applications are
probably going to
be written by many,
many people who want
to use a DSL module.
>> Exactly. So, I feel
that, like if you-
>> But I know it's both couple
that actually don't know
where [inaudible]
practical things.
>> That is true.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> So, before I wind up,
I want to thank MSR folks
for hosting us, and
being wonderful hosts for
all of us. Thank you so much